the weddell sea in antarctica is an icy
wilderness home to the penguin and many
other marine species
scientists from stony brook university
in new york have traveled to this remote
area on a greenpeace expedition ship
they're here to counter delhi penguins
to understand how they and other marine
species are coping with climate change
counting penguins is crucial because
penguins are an excellent indicator
species of the marine environment
they're much easier to monitor than most
marine species are because they nest on
land
they're big they're easy to spot
so we count penguins to get a sense of
how the marine ecosystem is doing
scientists say they count every group of
penguins by hand three times over to
ensure there's only a five percent
margin of error
where colonies are inaccessible drones
are used to take aerial surveys
the results show penguin numbers have
remained stable in this area in the last
decade
scientists say it's evidence the weddell
sea is a refuge against climate change
across the the western side of the
weddle sea at all of the adelie penguin
colonies that we've visited we've seen
some pretty good evidence for stability
in these populations which is quite
exciting because on the other side of
the antarctic peninsula delhi penguin
populations have really declined so
seeing
at least that stability for now means
that it seems at least that climate
change is is moving a little more slowly
in the wettle sea for for these species
at least
in 2018 the eu proposed making the
weddell sea a no-go zone for industrial
fishing mining and deep sea drilling but
the initiative was blocked by russia and
china
greenpeace says the results of this
survey bolsters the case for creating a
huge marine protected area
governments have for the last 10 years
been talking about creating a marine
protected area here in the weddell sea
this is just yet more evidence of why
that is so critical to protect places
that are still really healthy habitats
for amazing wildlife like penguins it's
just another reason why governments
should be acting now to protect the
world c while they still can
all this newfound knowledge will be
studied and compiled once the expedition
wraps up
researchers hope it can be used to
protect these unique waters and the
wildlife which lives in them
victoria gatenbee al jazeera